-Guys, the Kentucky Derby
is tomorrow.
Now, usually there's a horse
that's a clear favorite,
but not this year.
It's nearly impossible
to predict the winner.
Well, you guys are in luck,
because, when it comes
to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's puppies.
That's right.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's time for
"The Puppy Predictors:
2022 Kentucky Derby Edition."
♪♪
-♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Welcome to the
"Puppy Predictors:
2022 Kentucky Derby Edition."
Now, here's how it works.
We have eight adorable puppies,
each representing one of the
top eight horses competing
in Saturday's big race,
and one giant trough of kibble.
[ Laughter and oohs ]
Whichever puppy
crosses the finish line
and reaches the trough first,
they will be crowned
the Kentucky Derby winner.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Now.
Now, lined up at the gate --
starting gate,
we have the favorite, Zandon.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Then we have Epicenter.
Then we have Messier.
-[ Grumble ]
Mo Donegal.
-[ Yipping ]
[ Laughter ]
-We have White Abarrio.
Taiba.
Cyberknife.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
we have the long shot --
Simplification.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Simplification,
that's who I'm going with.
Alright, guys, before I relea--
What?
Cyberknife, focus.
[ Laughter ]
No, over here. Cyberknife.
Focus up.
Alright,
[ Awws ]
before I release you...
-[ Whimpering ]
-...no butt sniffing.
[ Laughter ]
No peeing.
No -- Alright, I want this
to be a clean race.
Hello.
Who are you again?
[ Laughter ]
Taiba.
No, no, no, get down.
No, Cyberknife!
Here.
No, you're not --
Simplification.
[ Laughter ]
Cyberknife! Cyberknife.
No, Cyberknife, stop talking.
[ Laughter ]
Cyberknife, over here.
Guys, stop mingling.
I just warned you.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Roots, whenever you're ready,
Roots.
[ Playing "Call to the Post" ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Okay, release the puppies!
[ Bell dings ]
Whoa!
Number 6!
I think it was Number 6, right?
Look at this right here.
Number s--
[ Cheering and applause ]
Number 6 is the winner!
Taiba!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Sting plays ]
[ Ohs and awws ]
Taiba.
[ Giggles ]
[ Awws ]
Oh.
You gave me a smacker there.
[ Awws ]
You gave me a real good
kiss there.
Taiba will be crowned the
2022 Kentucky Derby Champion.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Enjoy the race, everyone.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Sophie Turner.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hi, bud.
You did good.
Want to go eat more?
Go, go, go.
Go down.
Go, eat.